would you take that description from
revelling stone about being an
unreliable historian I I you know I
think I I haven't read it I don't know
what they're talking about I do know
that that I have been down this road
before and I heard the same things when
fire and fury was was published 17
months ago and as far as I can tell
every successive
account has confirmed what was in that
book well I mean what it's very clear
what your main source is in this book in
siege it is of course Steve Bannon the
former chief strategist to Donald Trump
of course one of the major sources in in
fire and actually he seems to me seems
to be subject and source well first
thing I think you're just repeating what
what you you've read and I suspect you
have not read the book which I would
love it to cover mr. wolf because I've
read it entirely which is behind it and
and didn't you find it incredibly
riveting I mean what the the whole point
of the book is to bring people into
Trump world to tell people exactly what
it feels like what the experience is is
is like and I think I've done this in
first book and second book as
successfully as as anybody it's quite a
I think any reader would find it quite
an experience okay this is quite an
experience it certainly isn't as some of
the experiences I don't think I can
share with our audience at the moment
but I want you to relate to some of the
experiences you described in the book to
the the state visit by Donald Trump's
just over to United Kingdom you got a
quote here from Henry Kissinger no less
former Secretary of State about foreign
policy saying that you know Donald
Trump's attitude to it is if someone
says something nice about him then they
are our friend if they say something
unkind if they don't kiss the ring they
are our enemy is it really that
simplistic I think it really is that
simplistic okay well I wanted to
continue on the theme of foreign policy
because your
describe how under brief how unwilling
to be briefed the president is you talk
about the president's even on his way to
that summit last year with kim
jeong-hoon in Singapore and Jim mattis
then defense secretary wondering if the
president even knew where North Korea
was on a map you know I mean let's not
mince our words here this is an
extraordinary presidency Donald Trump is
a figure like no one who has ever
occupied the the the office
intellectually emotionally sexually he
is at odds with with all past
assumptions about what a president is
supposed is supposed to be he goes into
these situations in in a way that no
president has has ever gone before he
went to the to the Helsinki trip
everybody rushed to Scotland carrying
all kinds of briefing books he was
staying in Scotland at his Golf Course
which he was promoting at the same time
they got there with the briefing books
of course he wouldn't look at them and
then so they reduced everything to one
page and he wouldn't look at that and we
saw the results in Helsinki well I mean
one thing comes clear in the in the book
is the the looming Muller report of
course say it came out it's part of the
the end of the book but he seems to have
survived that you know you know he seems
the the the Donald Trump mo is which is
you know all presidents come into office
they want to be in history or they want
to accomplish an agenda or they just
want to get reelected Donald Trump just
wants to get away with it and it would
appear that that maybe he's gotten away
with with with the Muller investigation
up until now but that doesn't answer
it's by no means clear that he will
continue to get away with it and I'd
submit that anybody whose threshold is
just getting away with it eventually
gets caught